[Music]
you're on your way to finding love who
the hell what a single girl doesn't want
to do I'm truly blessed I mean I had no
idea what I was walking into I felt a
little selfish saying you know what I'm
trying to find love for myself but I had
no idea would be like this you know I
had great men to choose from you know
it's no secret I found the one at this
point so I'm really really excited are
you wearing a ring yet no I'm wearing a
representation not the ring tonight they
won't let me as many times as I've asked
they won't let me because somebody could
see oh this person got the ring this
person got so the other day when we were
on the show Nancy O'Dell and I were
doing a story about you and about how
the guys go and pick the ring and then
they come to you and propose but we
thought this is 2017 why doesn't rachel
go get to men's rings and fight and
figure out the one she wants to propose
to would you ever do that yeah I'm not
opposed to any of that I'm all about a
Power Move but I did like the fact that
they picked the ring they get down they
asked me you know it feels nice because
I'm in such a power position this entire
show so it feels nice to let go of the
reins and let them in take who has been
the hardest to let go of so far well
just this past week I had to narrow down
from six to four and those two goodbyes
were so hard and I didn't hold back on
it and it was really evident it looks
like there's a front-runner it looks
like you're genuinely falling in love I
did genuinely fall in love on the show
I'm still in love now yeah okay I like
that
now tell me this because the news came
out that you once dated Kevin Durant
have you seen him since if you see him
tonight
is it awkward at all or is it just like
what's up well you know I went to the
University of Texas I've already run
into one long horn jerk Johnson just
walk through so you know like we're all
friends it's a small community when it
comes to UT in the african-american
community I've not seen Kevin tonight I
hope I do I want to congratulate him on
his new ring and he can congratulate me
on mine
[Music]
you